Alors, froid aujourd'hui ramène
à chaque fois cette question des
sans-abri, est-ce qu'on est bien
équipé, est-ce que le politique
fait son travail? Anie Samson et
Luc Ferrandez sont avec nous
encore cette année pour le panel
municipal. Bonsoir. Bonne année.
Un itinérant est mort à Notre-
Dame. Je vous fais écouter Mme
Plante qui a dit dans le cas de
cet homme qui ne voulait pas
aller vers un abri, puis il
avait assez d'abris. Le
problème, on va l'écouter,
encore là, comme les autobus et
la main-d'oeuvre.
VALÉRIE PLANTE,
mairesse de Montréal
- S'il doit y avoir d'autres
lieux, encore une fois, ce n'est
pas ça, le problème. La Ville
de Montréal a la capacité.
On a des... Il y a plein
de lieux qu'on peut utiliser.
Je tiens à réitérer que
le grand enjeu, en ce moment,
c'est le personnel qualifié.
- On a annoncé plus tôt qu'on va
prendre un stade pour créer un
abri, on avait ouvert les
stations de métro, Annie, est-ce
qu'on fait bien face encore une
fois à ces situations quand
elles arrivent?
- Je trouve que c' un
peu d'improvisation que l'on a
faite la même cho
dernière, on a ouvert le stade
de soccer, qui est encore, on
aurait pu l'ouvrir depuis les
mesures d'urgence que la vilquea
renouvelée en décembre et
janvier, la virulence le fait
aujourd'hui, il fait -1, ça va
être ce week-end. C'est un peu
tard. Chaque année, on a un
problème pour loger nos
itinérants de plus en plus parce
qu'il y en a de plus en plus, on
attend encore à la dernière
minute pre. Pourtant,
c'est décrit, on le sait, les
vers s'en vient, lorsqu'il fait
froid. Je pense que c'est une
mauvaise planification parce
qu'on est en mesure d'urgence,
on peut tout faire, mais là
actuellement, on a prie notre
temps où on fait un peu de
l'improvisation.
- Oui, moi aussi que je partage
le même avis, je ne comprends
pas, c'était prévisible, c'était
je sais qu'il y a deux
quartiers qui ont annoncé des
ouvertures de petits centres,
j'avais l'impression que c'était
mal raude ou problème
budgétaire, j'ai trouvé ça
lente.
- Épasse efficace.
- Ceci étend dit, c'est pas la
base du problème, la base du
problème, cette personne-là,
froid chaque année, il y a
vaillamment des morts parce
qu'il y a des personnes qui ne
veulent pas être dirigées v
des abris, c'est normal, ça
arrive. Le problème est qua
n'y a pas de place dans les
abris. Il y a une situation
particulière la COVID, mais ce
n'est pas que la question de la
COVID, s'il y a une augmentation
d'une nombre d'itinérants, et
maintenant on essaie de les
traiter avec plus de
professionnalisme, les groupes
qui traitent les itinérants, la
maison dd
Brewery,
approche où il tente dorénavant
d'aller plus loin que juste
donner de la donnée de la souris
du café et un point de chaleur.
L'approche psychosociale, la
recherche de logements, de la
santé urbaine, santé mentale, ça
c'est beaucoup plus
professionnalisé dans les
dernières années.
ir compte,
juste une petite chose ou de
sujet, mais il faut tenir compte
t pas justt pas justt pas justtn
abri la nuit qui va les aider.
Il faut être capable de les joue
jour. Actuellement, on a des
abris temporaires rapides, mais
le jour, les gens doivent être
aussi au chaud, c'est la même
chose, c'est pas mal très, très
mal qualifié pour l'instant et
le plan d'action qui a été
acceptée l'année passée de 1,4
millions auprès de tous les
partenaires n'a pas été mis en
place encore.
- Très bien. Les postes de
quartier, M. Carmant de la
police de Montréal dit que ça
fait son temps, il y a 30 postes
de quartier, il y en a trop, il
n'y a pas d'autres villes, on a
l'impression que le pendule va
d'un.. j'ai couvert la police
communautaire dans les années
80, l'orgueil découvre
aujourd'hui. Bref, on va
entendre Mme Plante sur cette
idée de couper des postes de
police de Montréal.
mairesse de Montréal
- Je vois ça d'un bon oeil
qu'on réfléchisse au SPVM,
à notre service de police,
qui est très important
pour la ville de Montréal,dans l
de l'augmentation malheureuse
du nombre d'événements
impliquant des armes à feu.
- Ça peut sembler contre
intuitif de dire : on va cou
des postes, sans mettre plus
sécuritaire. Comment vous voyez
cela?
- J'ai écouté ce que M. Caron a
dit à la commission des finances
en disant qu'il faut absolument
qu'on transforme l
parce que ça nous coûte 250
policiers de plus. Est-ce que
c'est les mêmes 250 politiques
Mme Plante s'est engagé à
financer qu'elle ne finance
plus? Paeeeeeeeeeee
les moyens, c'est vraiment gros.
J'étais là quand la police de
quartier a commencé, en 1994,
pourquoi on a installé, parce
que l'ancien système dans lequel
M. Caron veut revenir est une
police dépersonnalisée, un non
responsable d'un quartier, et
c'est ce qu'a fait la police de
quartier, je vous en parle avec
passion parce que ça été mon
grand débat depuis les 25
dernières années, a été de
pouvoir amener la police près
des citoyens, comment on est
capable de mieux servir le
citoyen, pas comment on est
policier.
- Il dit : oui, mais je vais
couper des postes mais il va y
avoir plus de policiers partout
sur le territoire.
- Mais les policiers sont
responsables de leur quartier,
connaître les citoyens, et
connaissent les jeunes,
connaissent les problématiques,
il travaille avec le milieu
communautaire. On va m'aider
politiquement paru un peu
partout sans connaître la
réalité locale avec les
problématiques, avec les
citoyens. C'est une grave
erreur.
- Il y a quelques mois, on
disait que le modèle de police
de quartier est excellent,
communautaire, vous le disiez,
longue des éléments en disant :
on va aller parler aux gens
avant qu'il y a un problème,
c'est la police de quartier.
Dans mon quartier, il y a eu de
plus en plus de police à pied et
de police à vélo et ça a un
impact important auprès des
itinérants, il les connaisse, il
leur parle, pas juste les
itinérants, les commerçants
aussi, rendant les commerces,
leur demande leur sentiment
général, vont donner des
informations que ça fonce très
bien. Est-ce qu'on peut encore
la payer? Ce que M. Caron
disait, c'est quand même
important. D'abord, le nombre
d'heures travaillées diminue
parce que on a une nouvelle
réalité, il y a de plus en plus
de femmes, dont des congés de
maternité, des congés de
paternité, congés parentaux. Il
y a aussi de la formation
continue, on ne traite plus
comme avant ne ramasse pas
itinérants pour lui mettre de la
voiture ou lui donner le convent
contravention que ça ne se fait
plus. Il y a de la formation
continue sur le racisme, donc il
y a beaucoup d'heures
disponibles qui ont disparu et
en même temps, il y a des
problématiques qui ont augmenté
énormément, donc dans les
rapports d'administration, on
l'a beaucoup vu, les filiales,
les armes à feu, la fraude, les
agressions sexuelles, la
violence familiale, c'est
surtout de la formation.
- On ne peut pas tout jeter à
l'eau comme ça.
- C'est un débat, ce n'est pas
fini, mais M. Caron a été assez
clair, il a lancé la discussion.
Il reste une minute, 30 secondes
chacun, taxi les non-vaccinés,
je sais que je sors de votre
cadre, mais taxé les... on parle
de gens vulnérables, Annie,
qu'en pensez-vous?
- Je pense qu'il faut trouver
une façon de pouvoir pénaliser
ceux qui sont non vaccinés pour
les pas que ça a sur notre
système de santé actuel, ce
n'est pas juste, ce n'est pas
que ils ont sur l'ensemble du
système qui est rendu fragile.
Si ce n'est pas une taxe, que ce
soit relevé lorsqu'ils vont se
présenter à l'hôpital ou s'il
décide de ne pas faire le
vaccin, ne pas prendre le
vaccin, qu'il nous signe une
entente en disant : je refuse le
vaccin et les soins qui vont
suivre... il faut quand même une
implication parce que ça a un
impact 90 % de la population.
- Rien de satisfaisante dans le
fait qu'il y a plus de... je pee
qu'il faut aller vers la
vaccination obligatoire que
c'est plus simple et ça ne
discrimine pas. Une personne
qui... les gens en déficience
intellectuelle, pauvreté, qu'on
lui donne une contribution parce
qu'elle est allée à l'hôpital,
en plus que ça ne peut pas être
une solution.